what's your revenue to date so far nine
point eight million pound in 16 months
nearly ten million ten million pounds
from selling nudes yep
making ten one two wait more sweet
telling me new then that's just on top
of whatever else the company makes fifty
grand a month some arms I'm going cuz
it's been the sex industry don't realize
how much you're discriminated against I
got an account with Barclays which is a
million quid through and they sent me a
letter said we need your pile into the
month we don't want your money basically
because it's their money allow it it's
funny because in the strip club over the
heirs the ones are Lucic when the most
was the bank manager cut but they were
they were the wall of this man we're
just doing all forms beneficial smoothy
funny over with thanks to you yes you
know in case you got any stubble rash
have you considered releasing it up
that's like vici yeah I was a bit like
cuz obviously said once a meet it's all
theirs but I was like do I want to put
me funny on the internet and I looks
like
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
Chelsea Ferguson in the building how are
you very good thank you thanks for
coming on so we do friends for ages in
France like 10 years and we've been
through I've been different jobs you've
been loads of different jobs first first
things first right
you're our party someone comes up to you
and says hi Chelsea I'm a new human who
doesn't know anything about you
what what do you do for work what's your
answer to that like it's like a young
crowd I'll just be bled out like my
pants are me like as a job and what's
not really Joe cuz I have sucked it on
cameras all know if it was like you got
even older woman which usually ones no I
am so it would be like an older person
and I would just say that I own a
website and then if they push me into
saying walk on your website I'll say on
website a porn website website yeah so
it's not the class of websites that
admire me is how's that yeah because
it's like idle entertainment isn't it
yeah and everybody's pretty much
shagging on there so if there is people
with dawned but like yeah it's obviously
not safe for work not definitely not
safe good work no yet so someone again
listeners some people know who you are
some people want what's admire me and me
is a website where men and women can
make up their own profile some couples
as well too and make your own profile
set your own price and then applaud
basically nudes pictures videos like
[ __ ] movies whatever you want to
applaud and you charge whatever you want
anything like charge extra for premium
posts and things like that so that's the
gist of it really and it's just been
crazy I didn't even think because of so
much free powers you think that it would
be like a thing really you know just
very much is a thing yeah so what's
what's your revenue today so far what's
on Oliver we're about nine point eight
million pound
sixteen months on trial well six a month
I think yeah maybe ten million ten
million pounds and over yeah ten million
pounds from selling nudes yep
that's a lot news it is about nudes have
you got any idea how many nudes it is I
don't actually that's an interesting
question
have you seen that's me like that's like
me saying to you some good news that
Chelsea not well I'm a professional have
you ever seen
pornhub at the end of the year they get
a data team they've got a big data
science team right in the backend that
do all the trends so it's like the most
popular porn in India and like how many
people are watching on mobile and what
the average blah blah so you should we
have got all I'd like to say like who's
on compute where who's on the phone and
like more stuff like that but I'm not
interested if I that's I never look if
you had over here yeah because I'm me
see your she has all she likes all
numbers and surprise out she knows well
I don't even of the logins for the buck
off like this is my company and our
toning of the login why are you not
trusted it's not it's not that I'm just
not just it's just that I don't care
like she she message me more I wouldn't
even hit in 10 be like she'll just fill
me in and I'll just you know I mean she
uh Tourister know what night what do you
care about with regards to the business
I do care like you know my point is
won't where is your like my job really
is like being relevant online make sure
I'm always like tweet earn like
recruiting new people getting the words
out there
are you more people arguing right viral
tweets viral Facebook there is as posts
whatever just getting be name out less
pause and more like just so people click
on me but I lose this and what exposure
yeah so that's my job I get you
so how do you stop how do you how do you
start thinking I want to make a website
where I can get amateurs a home and some
parole
as well as we had mutual friends yes but
yeah how do you why and though I was on
another site which done pretty much a
similar thing and their site was shocked
and they never spent any money on it it
was always breaking down and losing
money a friend sent her and they never
reply to emails for we take a site
that's as a what you told you so yeah on
mine we call it's VIPs but I'm not one
it was just but you were just a model I
guess yeah okay it was just that was
like under time for it
but um yeah they were just shy sit all
around so I was like I can't live like
this like this morning is mint but I
can't live like this like it was just
I'm suing you messed anything was a
nightmare so I said why don't we try and
make I was like make I wrong
so it was like 45 grand of my own money
I didn't get a loan I didn't know I
don't have rich parents like I literally
done it as a risk with my own money that
I made and we just like went all web
company and obviously just went from
there really
well you get 45 grand from I had started
because you've been stripping from
stripping and obviously I used to sell
notes on a different site and I just
like I guess I just had loads of money
already bought now we have mark yeah
well how hilarious is it you've you've
earned money on one site then use that
money to create their biggest competitor
yeah that's like so funny that's like me
winning a race in night shoes I'm using
the prize money from winning the race to
create a better pair of shoes and my own
brand well I've made like five hundred
thousand pound on this other website so
they couldn't just thousand-pound in in
Fitness after me yeah but they never
never like there was sheets or the like
I was losing money where they were cuz
there were things in whack and it was
just annoying me I paid him all this
money they didn't care I was emailing
they didn't reply for weeks and I've
sometimes even prior all I'm like what
are you taking this one Japan fall like
you let you take and it's dhul fiqar
with it so I was we were just sick so I
just decided to make that one so I get
you cuz I mean if you look at it from a
normal business
right let's say that you were some
stationery company which should
absolutely be not a favorite steak you
could be if you were stationary company
and you had a client that was worth five
million the Mavi wouldn't yet you'd have
an account manager they probably might
even assign them like a PA of some kind
of interesting car you must have been
that's why we we care like we are like
if you email us if we're aware you get
email back within like minister I mean
everybody has dealt with every single
situation gets dealt with passing so I'm
doing them like to sort it out like in
office in a few and we we actually
genuinely can want to be the best we
don't we don't as tables money in fact
the company itself I make more money
from selling my own nudes but the
company itself obviously makes a good
profit but every single penny pretty
much of the profit the company goes back
into the company costs a lot to run it
like a lot like one hundred thousands
tens and tens of thousands payments
where where's the car well yes online
advertising is it upkeep for what is it
just like the ad obviously the sheer
size of it there's been about four
hundred thousand customers have been
through it so it's just like the volume
of like people and obviously the the pro
hasn't it goes up to the cloud in the
sky or something this is like I don't
know that I'm not very good at computers
me so obviously we've got a team that
does all our but yeah go apparently to
keep it in this cloud in this guy costs
a lot more names so you got you you've
got your hosting stuff like that support
on the backend all the inquiries of some
guy who desperately wants to yeah we've
got my girls members of stuff in the
office all girls and like women and they
all on the site as well normally the
only one the only one that's monetizing
yourself yeah cuz they're all like
normal girls I guess like they're all me
sort of movie relatives people have
known for years I people I can trust you
know I mean so yeah it's crazy but um
twelve of them in the office and like
two of them I like over sixty and then
there's nine I don't and then there's
like old banking it was like far eh and
then Kim she's bought 37 and then the
others are like Yom Kippur
they're just I just have normal absolute
justice as far as that than the sick
medical cops are there but they're as
far as their concepts just a normal
office job like they don't see it as
anything else I just replied their
twitters you know your market any other
things like that I'm that's it okay so
you've spent forty five grand
yeah you've got this website what's the
website do like or what what's the crux
of it it's able to host images and
videos yeah under touch and money and
take money and we go to Sam's payment
provider Oh takes the morning and then
takes a little cotton link gives us the
money and all ah yeah that's it that's
why you're out you're a 45 45 grams
you've got this website and you've got
you when parrot it's yeah I mean the me
you know they followers that have
accumulated over the ten years of
meanest repair stuff so like what do you
do after that it's not just you know I'm
tons and tons people on that now yeah so
obviously I've got a lot of friends in
the industry I know a lot of friends er
was on this ship site so I was messaging
them like we've got a good site coming
out if he's are interested give us a go
and like everybody pretty much you're
come on straightaway I stayed on because
they loved it and all we keep toward his
obviously me a kind of better and better
and listening to people and see what
features they want and em yeah just like
making a bet every day who's trying to
be the best really I gave you some does
another 60 months ago September 2018
that is it terrifying like yeah the
numbers it what did he think he must
have thought like well we made a million
in the first three months okay so we $10
million three months yeah and and we
would it was just crazy because we come
in and loads of problems cause those you
would think like Luther amazingly more
money more problems I cuz it's been the
sex industry don't mean eyes how much
your em like
discriminated against so I I got an
account with Barclays which it up
million quid through and they sent me a
lesson and we need your bile into the
month we don't want your money basically
because it's dead money to them and
they've all their reputation and so I IV
out of Barclays Bank
couldn't get with any other Bank even
like the coops and all that I couldn't
get any of them bunks in England so I've
got a bank in Germany I've got a
personal van
son Daeron hum Fox didn't vote for me
business
I've got cause that's all 20 and yeah
basically I've got a bank in Germany for
that that's crazy
nobody wants find any money that's weird
it's funny because like in the strip
club over the ass the ones in Lucic win
the most was the bad manager they were
they were the walls man like so as I
mentioned bunking you were like chew
chewing they're getting VIP everyone
like they're the ones there was a guy
who used to come in every like three
nights so wait to see the same guy like
four years never done for anyone else
and just there and he was like one of
the top ones a hair chest they say have
you ever thought that it might be an ex
client of yours that's at Barclays he's
just thinking [ __ ] right Lance we need
to we really need to get that Chelsea
bird off because if she finds out that
is gonna be because I don't even read
awful yeah
okay so you you find it you've managed
to get yourself a bank account but if
you've done so you've been going 60
months if it took you three months to
make your first mill that means that in
the remaining 13 months you've done
eight which is actually even more
impressed on me than I actually not
negative yeah like that's yeah so okay
so when there must be a point where it
really really started to lift off what
happened that every single month that
goes up apart from January which is just
after Christmas this thing will not like
so much in January I think the one
because the one who's watching all the
free part in January cetera thought I
was but no this is obviously this one
spaceships it's just after Christmas
everyone skinned but every other month
leading up to that was like open open up
every single month was it was smashing
the month we thought so because the
models
subscription right it's not like you
don't buy photos I don't buy a photo
from you you buy a subscription to see
the photos and the videos i've got on
there i'm not so i don't know what I've
got on my 800 pictures videos for $14.99
over in and that's that rolls on every
month yeah oh you can cancel it straight
when you just pay the one-off kind of
thing see what you want to say and then
cancel it I was with you know everyone
that's listening
got some membership that they don't use
make sure to it I've got Netflix
literally like Amazon Amazon Prime I
literally didn't even log in or through
yeah it was a peon $8.99 month and then
my I am my Jimin hi I've got till Jim's
an article that I'm paying monthly I've
got one I'm meeting the one for about
eight months it's just been rolling on
twenty good a month so that's probably
what a lot of people do just like sign
up with anything that's cancer
yeah yeah I always do right and then
like that cumulative thing over time
obviously you know why yeah is why
you're gonna continue to get it so
coming to the girls and stuff to work
for you obviously
you're actually enabling a lot of people
girls and guys actually that's it that's
a question what's the split girls and
guys are we pretty much like ninety nine
percent women was like and all there was
a lot of guys to do it on other sites
like this [ __ ] one and we just didn't
really get we've got some guys on there
bore and mainly women I've got quite a
bit few couples and stuff like couples
of let you've seen that kinky sex life
or whatever and which is quite popular
as well but um yeah it's many women are
as fast majority think what it is I've
got all these followers from over the
airs they call me Twitter which is
obviously how I got like famous or
whatever I don't like 700,000 up one
plane but now I'm talking about 500,000
times in odd and but I can retweet like
the girls and obviously I've got the
party men waiting customers waiting
because that's who follows me I can't
really retweet a guy because I haven't
got guys
I even got like gay guys when should I
mean my followers are straight men yes
oh that's interesting
I've got a very narrow it's very large
but very narrow market yes yes meaning
yeah move one key yes yeah that's
interesting I think the thing that
struck me and it was the conversation
that we had with Sienna that really
really like shocked me was if you
haven't listened to that by the way
things will be in the show notes below
it's a conversation with a porn star he
was also a Chelsea psychic and she's
real funny he's only saying is he real
charming like great anyway
what she said was she is now in complete
control of her own income yeah
whereas previously in the porn industry
she would go work for browsers or yeah
and on top of that it's a she gets a day
rate I don't know what a day rate is
yeah five grand or whatever the other
day something I might have like told you
undersold in there sorry is she gets a
day rate and that's it like you've made
your money yeah and the content the
actual monetization of the content
occurs for browsers to DVD membership
site and you know all that like
reselling across onto adverts and stuff
like that where is now what you're
talking about is girls who are able to
create their own content I'm gonna get
you know this is a setup
that's probably far more sophisticated
than what almost any of the girls will
have on that when we're just filming
some of the YouTube we just do it all
falls form in a face to it's funny over
smoothie funny over you know with thanks
to you yeah you know in case you go you
still wash have you considered releasing
it up that's like VGA okay so we don't
have any we know that it's almost
exclusively girls yeah are on the site
what's the sort of content that people
are putting up you've said mostly solo
stuff you know what this video is it is
it photo is it what every single
profiles different like I can't say what
one passes is another and but one thing
that is a bit like crazy I don't know
what the word just but basically
everyone thinks all you've got to go on
there get smashed all over so everyone
off and that's how you make money
but like yeah I I've put some videos
like that of ex-boyfriends like you know
sucking them off and stuff right now but
some of me top earners who made over
like a hundred grand two hundred grand
like Amitabh Chan one of them all
needles topless she does do fully knew
before far away that not like Shawn dead
clothes and she's one of my top earners
another last Gemma Lucy
ooh you where she won't mind me mention
it she's she's one of me talk about
isn't she all he shows but she's I think
she was fully new but not like sex tapes
or anything quite a lot of the girls in
meetup 10 don't do sex with your saw
there is loads of girls that do laughs
but it tends to be the ones who went as
well-known like so they obviously feel
like that to put more compensation I
guess
yeah the daddy you get the more
subscribers you get what some gals who
already had followers people are just
talking you see then it balls through
that so you can still man what are you
just by your mind there's lots of girls
that do but it's about realizing what's
best for you and whether you want to put
that next step out there the guy was a
bit like cuz obviously said once a meat
it's all the airs but I was like do I
want to put me funny or lean and ass and
now it's like listening that was the
[ __ ] miming [ __ ] I mean movement
which is famous yeah I well that's
that's a good question I really want to
get on to which is you've got these
girls who were on there who are
completely in control of their own
earning their maybe making great money
now but their moods are on the internet
now they're on the internet what pay
world yeah people do see element so you
are this problem today right yeah
literally today you get when you walked
in you're like me news I've ended up on
the Internet no no I mean what's up
group your nudes and drove in a whatsapp
group like what so like there must be
some kind of lots of groups out there
there's just such loads of men in like
must be just a bath or whatever and a
couple of me may it's a message me like
obviously in the groups and then all you
know what's being put in this brew well
it's not the first time it's happened
obviously we all do the rounds like
basically someone will go on screenshot
armies [ __ ] and send it around yeah so
is that there's no way of securing the
content to someone can just press screen
record right and then your video on
their phone there's like I think that is
sometimes tough weather some banking
apps use wait if he's being shot doesn't
work or something but we I think we
don't looked into it and it was gonna be
like really hard to do and also people
want to do it they're just gonna get
another phone and take a picture sore
nothing is ever gonna be 100
say so you need to realize if you are
going to do this they are going to be on
there for your life they probably will
ruin any future prospects that you're
thinking about doing unless this is
going to be Korea and you're gonna smash
it buy some houses make sure you look
properly and don't be out of nothing at
the end of it but also at the same time
it's not like street food because I got
obsessed repairing it no you barely ever
seen I lost over 40 in the strip club
breakup was pretty much like it but in
this you do get like milfs and things
like that I mean because it's just
online I think people just think for
Coach that soldier was like I don't have
to physically go to the strip club so
people just keep doing it over a certain
age I guess and now so now you could
keep doing it for longer what do you
want to do when you're 40 50 probably
not depends if you've got if you make
until they I would say I keep doing it
till you stop making money and if he
still making good money why'd you stop I
think that's me why are you still
selling nudes when you own the company I
make some making 10 run to eat more
sweet telling me new like and that's
just on top of whatever else the company
makes or like why obvious you were to
start like 50 grand a month some arms
okay well I think the beauty is trim in
economics perspective the fact that it's
a membership site because it will
accumulate over time your churn rate how
many people actually end up dropping off
and yeah I wouldn't subscribe from
Chelsea's tits like a month or whatever
like you've got to presume that if until
you hit like a critical mass and there's
a lot of men that are aged like 18 to
feels a lot of men out that there's a
lot of men and women over at all men
might do if you if you conquer the world
of men with with your site that would be
impressive ok so we've touched on it
there like some of the girls might have
an issue then reintegrating back into a
normal job also I'm gonna guess like if
someone one of the girls was also a
employer Asda we get sucked yeah me
finally got stuck she was and we go for
the ones it helps all people in a home
or something
it can't yeah they they basically said
like you're gonna have to resign or
lucky economy
and because we've seen what are you
doing online it's unfair any because you
all you do with helping people plus
you're helping people just a good
all-around good girl no but like it is
chakra mainly that you can get sucks
with stuff right now there's some jobs
like other people I know I've got normal
jobs they would do it and like their
bosses know and they're like fine about
it but just those drums and I don't
actually know what she does you know
which is my group chocolate cheek she
does I think it's just like she's making
a receptionist or something like that
but it depends obviously who you bosses
and like what what the industry is us
pause and if you like a primary school
teacher yeah I mean exactly one of my
friends actually she wasn't always like
you or anything but she's a teacher and
she actually got a war on and at work
because it was when I must snapchat with
big you know a nice job millions people
on it and and like we weren't a night
out and I was like film and like wasn't
she pretended it touch me funny like her
and I was like it was just through just
like messing up and she went like that
thank you for clarifying
they literally printed it off it or big
like if what's that life-size like on
the board in school one was like and is
this you on Chelsea bags and suction and
she was like like looks a lot like my
fingers and she basically got like a
disciplinary or something over it and
like that was something outside of wear
on my snapped rubbish like nothing to do
have snapchat nothing and she got in
trouble over it so it seems like this
kind of to two cultures running in
parallel here right one of them is the
side that you're coming from which is
it's just nudes yeah doesn't matter
you know how anyone yeah and then the
other side appears to be the Barclays
Bank the primary school
concerns well the hyper sensitive yeah
to this sort of stuff I think I'll just
hypocrites to be honest cuz they're all
be freaking working on it like not one
man on this planet Patel maybe I'm
[ __ ] being on par so so why so I can
buy can you go on one over the people
carnal jobs like
is it does seem oddly like a double
standard it's I think it's something
about someone's private life is allowed
to be theirs privately yeah and the
concern is them when they make that
public yes and the maybe an older
generation isn't like an ick factor it's
still associated with sex work which
it's it's you know you're not it's not
like you're prostituting yourself to
someone you're not you know street crawl
in yeah yeah and bizarrely as well it's
if you were to look at it from a like a
public health safety perspective a lot
more a lot less dangerous than having to
be on the street all this sort of stuff
and you know everyone's got a phone yeah
so in one way or another I don't know I
I think it'd be interesting to hear
everyone that's listening
you know like leave leave your thoughts
in the comments below I really would
like to hear sort of where your stance
is on this do you think it's your job to
warn the girls about the implications of
being on the site do you have like a
process do you be like look you kind of
need to be aware that this is gonna be
around or I don't think it's my job
I think obviously these are adult so you
have to be 18 but I do stress it a lot
like I've done make my own YouTube
videos if anyone wants to check those
out and and I was like eh
okay Q&A though I got Miami and hotnet
money's right up and in that I do say
like the people safe can you do it
anonymously I'm like look yes you can do
it no no it was anonymously but nothing
stays anonymous for long in this world
you only I would you do well yeah yeah
basically and some gals do still make
money people but all check system one
goal I know that's had salsals bedroom
like you can tell your about someone's
[ __ ] CI tahu she does that tayo
looking do it a bit more and then it's
all exposed cause [ __ ] be [ __ ] and
people can't stand to see anyone else
doing anything so obviously they're
trying doing a good thing for you so I
just I do warm people and say like this
is on the in there for the rest of your
life so just make sure Thresh you in
there but younger as well like a chain
and soft like you make these knowing a
much and so to see you know I do when I
would say anything that now I'd be like
a boss yes officer
you did when you were about twenty one's
probably only Nestor you you either you
had like a quick take off with that
industry so what are the other things
that I wanted to talk about was a
facebook status that you put up recently
yeah um you what I tell you what why
don't you describe what you posted and
so I don't like cause a ruckus to be
honest lucky so I posted a picture of me
house which is a five bedroom detached
house who double gamut and I had my
Lamborghini and my Range Rover Sport on
the drive and I've got Chelsea on the
lumbar and fair go on the Range Rover
that's my number plates and if anyone's
to check the picture out with me on my
Instagram Chelsea Fargo and and I put it
on Facebook the picture and the caption
was all from showing me funniest
strangers wasn't it then like subscribe
here like help me put petrol in my life
yeah all from showing me funny to
strangers help me put pepper aluminum
ball and then the link and it got like a
common bond we share thousands and
thousands of shares sounds in the
comments noise in like the start of it
all of you yeah I was having a few
different webpages and everyone was like
call me Wes and [ __ ] that's some of the
stuff later on I'm like oh we're on Mike
just our voyage I like you don't even
like say it's like why do you think
people react that way so [ __ ] jealous
like people can't bear the fact that
just getting me finding out has got me
all that do not mean they think you'd
have some money but not as much like if
I was show me find it live on for free
right the be all over it the minute I'm
making money offer to the door like it
the minute I've got the car the dream
car that most men would [ __ ] stick
their [ __ ] in the exhaust if they could
like let's the be like the best cat one
of the best cars in the world like and
I've got it and that's why people don't
like it but I [ __ ] worked out I've
played my gym without asked to
McDonald's or to and off yeah I worked
in Bakke where I'm washing pots I wax in
call centers away from water for I was
thinking shoot every [ __ ] day I used
to work one do it Friday 9:00 to 5:00 in
a call center Friday night Saturday
night in a nightclub all three non then
Saturdays from today McDonald's and that
was
like from like 17 18 19 like a [ __ ]
baton and I got done the [ __ ] jobs or by
kana do this now like I end it so you
know I think rightly so because there's
people that are doing much more
outlandish things and making much less
money and being given much less [ __ ]
there was some real victory or comments
I had a little bit of a scroll through
and and had a look at the minute people
are really really becoming upset they're
very very upset and I think I think a
lot of it is them being triggered by the
fact that they probably work harder than
me now they probably work 70 hours a
week door get to see the family whack
away from their family and don't get
arrival I'm bored Orion Gator of the
ridge like don't get a have a house but
that's not my fault
because men you men created the industry
you are the parents who want to pay for
it so why why should I you be mad at me
because someone give me the option to
make the morning I see fruits of their
labors yeah like you know I mean like
use all want to see it so if you can't
see it you then I make money like that's
just [ __ ] yeah it is it's so
interesting that you have this this
level of jealousy and as well you are
right there is a the amount of work that
you need to do now to earn the money
that you do in compared with that of it
you know like when you think about your
hourly wage now compared to the hourly
wage from McDonald's it'll be orders of
pound an hour
Wow for also showing your age a little
bit there're that would've been when it
we've been legal - it's fine I was on I
was on this it was three I was somewhere
else before that cafe and I was on 360 I
think there that was I was 15 when I'm
around 16 and I was entitled to full
upon 10 an hour yes in fact I just about
waiting for Thursday Friday Saturday
always get picked always come on the
takeaway always go talk to your and
always still Armani myung like things
were cheap back there like five bottles
for a fiver in that I don't think that
you really need to worry
anymore no I know but still annoys me
that I can't shake things used to be now
they're not I know it's all relative you
one of those people that posts about the
price of freddo's every couple of years
like the freddo's have gonna buy another
five panels Fred girls are a lot bigger
student do note for me okay I'm a
[ __ ] oh jeez so yeah I think it's a
lot of it is the fact that it's it
appears from the outside in
easy money or as you like unearned money
unjustified money yeah but this is the
bizarre thing you look at anyone anyone
who has come up with a product that has
a disproportionate place in the market I
could do with Johnny and Yusuf here to
explain this bit put the kid who made on
the fault have you heard of unfold it's
an app that allows you to make really
pretty Instagram stories it's actually a
life hack in a previous episode that we
featured this this guy's made it some
dude in America he's maybe 20 he's early
twenty something like that he's just
sold it to Squarespace and the people
that make websites like Wix calm or and
then make it low you design your website
1 billion I don't know what he is he's
under 30 that's 1 billion
it's like well duck duck hit there has
done a thing he doesn't need to work for
the rest of his life snapchat as well
whoever made that so that's a comment
about huge to Facebook it was he
Facebook bought Instagram didn't their
they bought they buy all them what's up
yeah what's up Facebook Instagram and
snapchat think are all owned by the same
person
so all they did was make an ID audits
that was for nudes originally
self-challenge
then assumes at the bar by Facebook I
will [ __ ] kicked off will be 10
million followers I was livid it's how
many people you had and stuff haven't
envy always ice to get on me sorry do
you know all over the world like it was
crude that was a crazy time you know I
could didn't being a millionaire then if
this to be hunk then but it wasn't
because you develop I was millionaire
now but I mean I'm big a million excess
to the market back then more easily yeah
like I literally anything I promised I
used to get people calm at the strip
clubs and k1 for me and that was in you
cuts a little margin if it have been a
site on last so one of the maddest
stories I've got
you and this is going back a little way
you'll be able to tell me what it was I
want to say like eight years ago so is
when you were going and doing the
nightclub PA yeah
so you'd fly over to Ireland and do a
nightclub PA like a reality yeah person
in the club the fiber equator Granderson
yeah and then go and strip on the night
time in like a local strip club I didn't
do it an alley but the afternoon all the
places where it was like a I'm gon do
the PA and then strip as well so I would
like make like a feel grunt can you do
was it's a thingy Rhino semen right I
don't know I don't love by moles first
birthday when they first started I was
at their guests and spam Rhino under
stripping or just a suggestion
could you imagine if a lad Bible lad
Bible if you're listening how the [ __ ]
do you get away with some of the stuff
that you post you had Chelsea Ferguson
at your first birthday party getting it
yelling at me funny else it's just funny
creating your phony on for 20 quid but
also the dead I'm doing mr.pan actually
can't be asked I just looked it like it
was fun I said a little meeting people
like my fans or ever you wanna call them
I said love me well like I still have
getting through with them they said
obviously make money but Isis like even
if it was me back there I was like you
gone off you better might go to wax I
had more fun in the strip but then I
don't like don't mean I have more fun in
there so I don't miss it for this is not
a part of my life anymore I couldn't go
back now I went to get into this as well
actually so the the girls that work in a
strip club anyone who's been in a strip
club will know that the girls are a
community there right it's the same as
any workplace people yeah but it's a
very unique environment there if you had
a daughter would and she said hey mum
I'm concerned 20 years old I'm 21 years
old I'm considering of going and
starting stripping what do you think
you'd he'd say I think I've always
thought like yeah look I'm gonna have my
daughter and a boss I think if I did
have a daughter I'll probably think
different because I know that the drugs
that comes with it like everyone's on
Cork everyone's like you know that's
part of the job what why do you think
it's father Joe
because it gives your way so [ __ ] sick
smile like so like it's unless you run
there was loads of gals of friggin
dropped away I can draw a wall like such
normal young people but like Laura the
drugs went on and that's where like a
lot of people like hard and try this and
they're like and then the parties and
yeah I think that would be the bit that
put me off really but I think knowledge
is just something kids taking drugs it's
probably gonna happen anywhere
I challenge increased for you though so
it's not as if you're just thinking yeah
yeah fine darling get cracking yeah yeah
it's not about I don't care about the
the getting there apart and cuz they are
you are safe like your ass if and the
curbs like obviously with the bombs
rather certain clubs you might not be so
multiple the ones I was in you wear and
the way I'm torching you or anything
like that sort you can do it and is if
like I think if it wasn't the drugs then
yeah I would probably say yeah why do
you think the so the atmosphere that
you're talking about there right the
girls and stuff like that
I really want to try and get into the
effect of girls treating men as
transactions yeah because I'm friends
with some strippers and you'll be
friends with hundreds and there is with
some of them what I think is a negative
mindset about men I just don't trust
them okay
every time men have come in the strip
clubs and stuff they're on their stag do
they get married they're trying to get a
[ __ ] like literally like the ones
that then they'll be born as one who
sits in the Chronicles I don't want done
since I've got a girlfriend I'm in LA
oh how cute sorrow cute and then after a
few drinks inside our [ __ ] Guam and
then he's the last one gone wrong what
you [ __ ] here I'm like I have faith in
you
you let us all down give me money so
it's sort of to like trust people and
like I have so many choices trust issues
from the strip club like I'm gonna just
startin to like probably forget not
forgetful
like me boyfriend now like like
everything he tells me I'll just take it
as a truth which is obviously what all
these other girls take their boyfriends
who've been asking me for a [ __ ] so
like you just don't know what I believe
do yeah but you can if you like
being cynical like that or I think
getting away from the soup club has
helped me away it also killed my sex
life my sex drive I never wanted to have
sex I will be posting about that along
along was literally for the 10 years of
a stripper here it says I never wanted
to be sexy right a home I was there
being sexy after we're putting on the
act of being sexy but soon when I was at
home I was in a juicy truckie I wasn't
shaving me funny all wait till my next
shift like I was a little too like I've
got no interest in sex at all and that's
and then obviously that like affected me
relationships and stuff right that bore
I just I think a real no I did ruin it
for me
all the strippers actors as well the
analogy that I draw for people when they
talk to me is I hey man like you've got
the night off this weekend you wanna go
out yeah I understand that you think
this is fun what you do for fun is what
I do for work exactly I like that yeah
and I can kind of see that with you the
unique thing I love the outliers in
these situations and Seanna who was sat
here is a pure outlier so Johnny was
like you know you you've been at work
all day you've been DP'd by two huge men
from Amsterdam or whatever and you get
home any boyfriend says like honey do
you do you fancy yes yes you fancy
having some sex this evening and she was
like no [ __ ] it what's it worth because
she's one of those girls that bill hard
she seems to be built for the ex-wife
yeah that's why I should do that cause
she's horny but you might class yourself
a little bit more as a sexually anomic
blood like that plunge me where I feel
this industry like pretending I'm a
horny [ __ ] like you know it's not it
wasn't true like now I'm in a
relationship with somebody that I love
like I'm like it's different but when I
was in relationships with all like it
wasn't the same Jo I mean it was like it
was tough and I just didn't feel it at
all and people never believe me I sauce
be like I'm nurse like me you know I'm
[ __ ] boring and I still sound bore
and now I'm like missionary with the
lights off and now okay no that's not
completely true and both sometimes all
that's wrong
so sometimes we did in there it gets
wild sometimes it's on the couch not
just
ya know people ask me things like
there's a wild space about sex I'm like
on the couch that's true I've never
[ __ ] of sex in anywhere crazy like I
wouldn't double mic just I like to be
comfortable this part of the discussion
that we're having here where people seem
to think that it's this window into your
life and I think that's part of the
attraction of sites like read mind me
and I think this is I'd like to get you
on this why I think that these direct to
client or direct to consumer sites like
yours are effective is that it feels a
lot more personal personal yeah right so
go to free pour
you don't know anything about Miguel and
this song so [ __ ] stupid like I don't
know what she's been up to today I don't
know what her likes and dislikes are
done by America now but like that's what
people like like if you live in the
street right says the fifth gal who
lives at number [ __ ] 20 right in u.s.
oh Sierra Vijay gone where and you know
I wonder what our song looks like so say
this opera often wonder them well I just
like not personally well I've said what
men are like they would look at AG and
be like oh she she's like say like a
cute girl next door type who you would
never believe in a million as I'm sure I
knew makes you wanna see even more like
someone's out there with the funny flaps
out already a bit like more saying it
Johnny but if you tease if you want your
your chains on you don't intentionally
even you might go about your daily
business men are intrigued by it so then
they're like I wish it was an option to
see her naked now there is and then the
like obviously I'll bet you any money I
adored all the statistics but yeah any
money that most of my subscribers will
be people I know personally I can just
imagine it will be people I've known
from school with people who are whacked
and mcdonnell's but there'll be people
who've known me for years you all
wouldn't is what we finally looks I know
they know it's not they can now they can
find out for it for a mirror thing it's
49:59 discount available so yeah that's
that's it that's the reason why I think
people like it they to the fact that it
feels very fast you can track to them so
okay so it's kind of interactive is yeah
so people chucked yeah they want to know
what you've been up to
what's your
not got you must suffer have to have a
PA for all of your subscribers
I've got like I had about 3000 at one
point but like subscribers but I'm at
about 2,000 what's this January and not
every single almost a message so some
people just want to go on from number
one god I mean and that's fine but then
there's I think it was just some I'm
some lonely people out there OneNote
chat to you because they might not have
anyone else to chat to which is
obviously is quite sad really poor like
that's another it's just a service that
you provide like they might not want to
see an escort because they might not
feel comfortable do or not that might
not be confident
I just want to track to you and protect
you there online girl from know
something like there's nothing wrong
with that like it gives them a bit more
of a personal experience
some people might be their June they
might not dare go out there some people
have mental health issues they might
feel like too anxious to speak to a girl
especially somebody who's like also does
what we do like you wouldn't talk
probably come up the talk was like quite
intimidate and so there's all these
reasons really the people wouldn't
understand I guess and I say you in that
situation
hmm completely yeah I want to get back
to the conversation about the
relationships thing do you think that
the girls are on the site so we've
talked about stripping and some of the
side effects of that and I think that's
super interesting that girls are
strippers see a very particular
demographic in men yeah that inevitably
it
no man is it is most honorable in a
strip club even the one who doesn't do
anything yeah there's titties everywhere
you know cause we self in our Garret on
it's like I found out myself so
obviously they cannot yeah so so that's
that's one particular part of it but the
girls that are working online do you
think that they're potentially gonna
come up against some relationship
problems they've got to have a very
specific type of boyfriend that's gonna
be accepting of his girlfriend getting
naked on the internet his friends could
pay you know it's a common joke in some
of the workshops that wearing words
you'll see a guy start to go out with a
girl that girls on that on your lap hang
in a second make fifteen quid I can see
your girlfriend's vagina yeah I know but
I all artists think like how many girls
you probably know how many girls funnies
have you seen in town like gals of you
our nurses it will teach you to a normal
job but they've sent the news to one
person and
that happens all the time so just
because I have charged from honest
recent ads for free and everyone's still
seeing it because that's what happens if
you anyone who's ever sent a nude has
been seen by more than just the person
who you feel consented to don't care
what you say so at least I can say like
I've got four compared for mine and
prepared plenty but there's a better
relationship thing I think it actually
helps sex lives if obviously if if
you're already doing it and you meet a
guy he must obviously know what you do
so he's accepting it because these chose
to be with ya knowing that you do it in
the first place
and then I guess if you were just
started doing it when you'd already had
a relationship I'd say making your own
relationship bring together yes
and then I say why don't we do this like
we make videos like they could do it
anonymously a lockable serve like your
face wouldn't be in it like you could
wear a mask on or whatever and like
people do do that and I think it
probably helps some SEC tribes as well
because you feel like oh let's make some
videos of it nor even like it's a bit
kinky and everyone's different and
everyone has a different like what
they're in no kind of thing but it's
also people you least expect as well if
people do it anonymously with normal
jobs and you're like like secret date
little secret over like some there's so
many different people on there it's not
just like people like me like sale
there's me [ __ ] kind of thing out
there everyone knows just affects and
lives in articles that's aerosol there's
lots of like people who do it like you
know I mean is the more like so all
about it yeah I understand what you mean
I think that the final concern that I
have the final question I've got
regarding relationships and this is
specifically a problem with girls and
it's one that I see in strippers and I
know that you will have done as well
it's when girls see men as transactions
not investments so they don't see
themselves needing to actually put care
or attention into a man because their
industry that man is just let's say
you're in a strip club it's a 20 pound
dance leap and dance let's say that
you're online that man is just a 15
pound subscriber if you ever noticed in
yourself or in any of the girls that are
around you like that kind of
culture coming through well I know some
girls I want to be good friends actually
who lives in London she's actually a
escort and she's hasn't had sex for free
in over five years
she says I'm from to have sex for free
like she literally has no interest in
being in love no interest in being in
relationship to her everything is a
transaction you're if you want to speak
to her if you want to take her for
dinner
everything is a transaction with her
that's hair personally me I'm like an
old romantic I love Ben and love I love
being in a relationship and I am in a
relationship now I'm really happy and
yeah like for me it's I have quit
stripping for somebody before and it
wasn't always about money for me I lost
the job I loved making good money but
that wasn't the be-all and end-all of it
to me but there was girls like my friend
who all she cares what is the money she
just you know she was like that before
did you ever know before me I even known
her that long and but she just doesn't
care
after all like she gent she's I've got a
month mindset you're like some men who
were like just [ __ ] chocolate all the
care about they have no interested being
in love some people she's like that you
think she'll change I don't think she
ever will
like she it's a true like who she is
like she doesn't care about any any man
thanks how old is she if she's older
than me she was 37 okay yeah looks
amazing you gotta be a very unique woman
I think personally you have to be a very
unique woman to get to 40 without kids
yeah and look back and think that was
the right decision
well that's not me saying that there
aren't girls out there for whom that's
the truth and there are there's some
real high performance there's women who
just don't want to have families there's
men that don't have families and they
can create perfectly loving partnerships
and beautiful families without children
exactly you know like dog mom take this
yeah but I do worry that some girls
might be prohibited from having a
relationship perhaps because they
struggle to find a partner who's
comfortable with what they do or did
perhaps ones who maybe have reframed
relationships
it's kind of new way transactional thing
I don't really enjoy sex anymore sex has
kind of been a bit it's the job yeah
it's been dirtied for me somehow and you
know I I just I think it definitely
seems like you're coming out from the
right standpoint and it's nice to hear
that the person at the head of the
company has your mindset as opposed to
your friends from London yeah because if
it was that much more aggressive
militant money-making mindset that would
inevitably trickle down to the girls if
your boss boss boss boss never has a
relationship doesn't care about someone
I don't think that's such a tremendously
healthy example for what most girls just
they should have most girls should have
relationship there should be in and out
of romantic relationships same way that
most guys should be in and out of
romantic relationships think about
change you know Chris honestly like
girls realized that we don't need for
good men anymore like that is the truth
like think men are good because they
kind of lost their like that power I
guess women have took took off and are
like we're like if you want to fit into
my life like this is what I do this is
what I've always been like anyway
obviously I look pretty loved but I've
always never compromised who I was for
anyone so I've always said this is made
this walk done this is what I'm gonna do
you either fit into this life or you
don't fit in Hawks I'm not changing this
is me and I've done it before change for
somebody and it ended up being none he
lost everything he lost everything on a
wooden arena it's haunting on this
conversation like it he tried to make me
lose every single penny that I add and
luckily I ended up [ __ ] them off in
the end and thinking no you know what
and all I'm capable of something amazing
and Here I am now but like like I said
I'm in love now and I'm really happy and
like approach I'm not to change anything
about myself like they lost me to
exactly who I am life and literally
everything about me so I don't need a
like change anything but men just might
because we're kind of like women all
money we're traveling the world we're
buying everything ourselves wears before
men were like we are alpha male we make
money woman stay at home and that's what
a lot of men's minds have still like I
wouldn't make had wifey [ __ ] you won't
[ __ ] got nothing I want anyway like
what the fool you would make me why they
love you go if we couldn't be I'm w1
lace I mean I think in that situation
they would be your wifey well exactly
but like you know I mean it's just
everyone's entitled to be happy if
people want to be relationships being
relationships you don't wanna be don't
be don't do it and just do what makes
you love me and I've always done that
part from the one time when I sucked
everything off so hot I'm going to give
this a real chance I'll stop stripping
I'll do it normally and it just like
actually it made me sit unhappy made me
not believe I was it made me try and
like fit into this real well to the real
job where it just wasn't me like I
didn't want to do that again like I
think on you when you look at it now so
there's top and athletes who need to
make a decision between the sport and
their family right you know you're a
female sprinter who's 30 years old
you've probably got maybe another
Olympics or another couple of Olympics
and that's it but also that lie
illogical hearts going and you think you
might hang in a second I need to make a
decision here between whether on a
family do I want to continue down this
road with my sport
everyone who's making these men do it
women do it in high pressure positions
people that are lawyers that are doctors
stuff like that working long hours they
would need to take time off potentially
take a pay cut not be overlooked for
promotion all this saw stuff happening
all the time the difference is that the
industry is dominated by women the one
that you're talking about and it was
only a hundred years ago that women
didn't have the vote they own you now in
the next like 20 years like things are
gonna be even more different
iving and women are just gonna like I
know more and more lesbians now like
this is crazy I know more more girls it
won't you gonna cheat on you
normal-looking lesbian and they're
getting in relationships with girls
good-looking girls of each other because
they're just for a second man like I
honestly like it smart as everything's
changing so many weeks sink
the problem with us being relationships
is that they need men to make more
lesbians you know I mean you can't have
more lesbians without more men but I
totally get it and you know bizarrely
from from my side as well like the sort
of girls that I'm attracted to a girls
who have agency over their life for me I
get one interested in a girl as soon as
I sort of know everything that there is
to know and I'm no longer challenged or
engaged with them so bizarrely for me I
probably should actually start looking
on at my me for a girlfriend
well I don't want to pay 15 $5.99 okay
when the discount codes are up you can
let me know another but yeah it will be
interesting to see what happens you've
this sort of industry now that is being
created that director customer photo and
video membership site as far as CN is
concerned she's been in the porn
industry for quite a while has
completely changed the game for that
so what happens next right like do you
just keep growing the site yeah we're
trying to make the site is best we can
and then and just I don't know I wanted
to do like I want to go into all the
areas of like other fields not so much
the sex industry I wanna quit having
normal things okay I don't know what yet
so here's a question actually a good way
to sort of round it up one of the
concerns we've spoken about today is the
fact that girls are potentially
restricted with what they can do
career-wise outside of that so you must
have set meself up we money basically
that's not one side Moses or but getting
yourself doing some girls do it on the
side from doing nails and then buy your
own shop and you know things like that
you can do yourself restaurants bars you
know I mean the freaking beauty industry
now hair beauty the song or 20 and up
now like like miracle things like that
never ever gonna charge on like nails
extensions eyelash extensions everyone I
always got freaking eyelash extensions
like everyone or another one can be
asked every other every other last time
to ask them on every other last time
individual ones everyone's doing it so
an and like sixty quid you know for them
like six and I was doing sort people to
make and good morning there's all these
different industries that you could put
your money into courses to learn more
things and we use go get that capital
and yeah potentially save you money
obviously don't blow all on like Louis
Vuitton oh [ __ ] like a lot of oh and a
quarter million pound turn back what was
a hand thank you run about uh I've got
what was mine ahem Emma's back and I've
got a seven-run mine wasn't
hürmüz beckon okay and but there is one
that's right children obviously yeah
like obviously lost your phone on a
night out and lost the handbag I've lost
it a grand phone in a seven grand town I
would never take that humbug out yeah
obviously I bought on board stuff like
that and that was because I've already
got two hours that I own outright with
no mortgage and yeah you already got
another how much stuff and I just felt
like treating myself to swings crazy so
I got the lumbar but I could have bought
under the house for that but like I just
think [ __ ] it you only live once or yeah
I think especially with the sort of
income me you guys have got good yeah
what's good random one so I'm gonna buy
some property rent them out and then I'm
looking into like all their businesses
that Awards there's already like I don't
know if definitely her up okay
yeah that's just mean like really it
sounds bizarrely and one of the things
that hopefully be really interesting to
hear from the people have been listening
today is were you the person that they
expected to hear like I would like to
hear I will say that surprised by me
obviously my YouTube video short bit in
my personality which I've only just
started doing but I don't know this
moment you've normally as there's more
to me than just tits and ass and funny
I think I'm not yeah but like I am like
a normal person underneath like you're
just boring if anything I just like
sitting in the office and we jobless
when we dogs welcoming dogs you know I'm
just like normal person mainly you just
happens to have shown me body and made
some money but I don't feel any
different as a person I don't feel
readily but no self-respecting so right
out of my self-respect is like choose
and to do something that I've chose to
do being happy Conlon
make money not hurting anybody I can
sleep at night knowing I'm doing what
I'm doing for myself
I mean mum was proud of me like you know
I mean like she she was probably she was
to like show everyone me nuts and zoo
covers and like in the shop she went
from Tesco she lets my job and somebody
that she loves probably me so I mean
Doug doesn't care at all like I know if
I think okay you Claire was that an
example which I said lid Barker like
he's just like doesn't care at all I
always joke about being a pastime for
him and stuff
she's in care when he gets a Sunday lift
to the pub in a Lambo he probably thinks
when he didn't she would on it's all
want you say bang me cause I'm gonna
come to see lose endure my heart girl so
I'm gonna pop down I'll come see you for
a bit and then can I take your car on
screwdriver
yeah if you want so it comes down come
see me for a bit then goes for driving
the car then takes is how you die yeah
dad we'll do a car swap for the week you
could get the docs in the high-end dive
because you can't get them in the Lambo
no no that's why I kept the red drawer
because the boots big enough for the
dogs yeah it's just nightmare like the
lumbar saw impractical impractical
weather why does anyway it's not
possible it's very fast
yeah look why should people go they want
to find out more about you they want to
find out about the site they've got an
inquiry where do they go if you want to
see me kids for free go on we Twitter
app shell spag or if you want to see
what I got at aura databases my
Instagram our Chelsea flag or if you
want to come and see me funny me hassle
and they still gonna dick and admire you
leave dot VIP /lz Perigord there you go
that's all you need that's below thanks
professionally thank you
[Music]
you